foreign
[Music]
hi guys it's Quinn here if you enjoy my
videos consider hitting the like button
it's the only way the YouTube algorithm
really notices me
the southern reach is a science fiction
Trilogy by author Jeff Vandermeer some
weeks ago I released a video covering
the first book in the series
annihilation
Annihilation which was adapted into a
film in 2018
introduces to us the mystery of area X
though the first book excellently sets
the stage for one of the most authentic
Cosmic horror Tales since H.P Lovecraft
the mysteries of the series really
unfold in the following two books
Authority and acceptance
each of the books were released in 2014
Just months apart from each other now
that I've finished the entire Trilogy my
recommendation is to read them as a
single book
as the three together tell a complete
story
these three books definitely make up one
of the most mind-bending trilogies that
I've read in the last few years
in this video we will Journey beyond the
border into the mind-breaking corridor
of area X
what is the secret of area X why is it
here
what does it want what is the other
worldly creature known as the crawler
who etched its Eerie sermon along the
walls of the tunnel referred to as the
tower
what role did the Lighthouse Keeper play
in all these strange events and what are
the motives of the mysterious
organizations the Seance and science
Brigade and the southern reach
this series is one of the most
interesting Cosmic horror stories that
I've read it maintains its mystery but
provides satisfying answers to many of
the primary questions for those that
look hard enough
in my opinion this Trilogy can be seen
almost as a retelling of HP lovecraft's
the color out of space essentially it is
a first Contact story and like the color
out of space it points out that our
definition of life might be quite
limited given the vastness of the
universe who knows what strange forms
may come into existence and who can say
how contact with life on Earth would
affect said entities
and what effect they may have on us
for reasons that remain obscure it all
begin at least from the perspective of
Earth along the Forgotten Shore assure
that it long been known to conjure
Twisted stories among its inhabitants
there were plenty of eerie whispers
about things seen and heard
something had happened there
30 years prior to the events of
annihilation
the event
in present day the place is devoid of
human life and nature has reclaimed it
it is now area X
this video will contain Major Spoilers
for the southern reach Trilogy so if you
haven't read them and spoilers are a
thing you care about I suggest you pause
this video and come back to it after
you've read the series otherwise
continue forward
part one the beginning
the origin of area X
the Forgotten Shore had been a strange
place for as long as anyone could
remember it
the stretch of land along the Pacific
coast was no stranger to ghost stories
and more bizarre tells still
fishermen often brought back stories of
strange things they had seen swimming
just beneath the water line
a small town nearby was home to about
1500 people
one of which was the Lighthouse Keeper a
man named Saul
we first learn of the Lighthouse Keeper
in the first book Annihilation but his
significance is not fully revealed into
the final book in the series acceptance
Saul was one of the first people to come
into direct contact with whatever it was
that caused area X to become what it
eventually became
in book 3 acceptance we learned that
roughly 30 years before the events of
the first book in the series the area
was regularly studied by an organization
known as the S and SB or science and
Seance Brigade the connection between
the S and SB and the southern reach
organization which would later send
Expeditions into area X is at first not
clear the SNSB seemed to be an
organization with a dualistic purpose or
at least that is to say members in that
organization had different ideas about
exactly what it was they were studying
and how to go about studying it as their
name would suggest the nature of their
experiments related to both science and
mysticism something about the Forgotten
Shore and the island off its Coast
interested them
the organization had been given a permit
by the government to study the coast
their headquarters was on an island just
off the coast
known as failure Island
the island was named as such because all
previous attempts to settle the island
had ended miserably
on the island still stood an old ruined
Lighthouse the lens and Saul's
Lighthouse had previously been the one
to light failure Islands
the island itself was not unfamiliar to
Strange Tales in a way it almost seemed
cursed
strangeness was nothing new for failure
Island if you listen to Old Jim or some
of the other locals The Mists of the
Forgotten Shore had always included that
Island
even before the latest in a series of
attempts at settlement had failed
the rough unfinished Stone and wood of
the town's buildings the Island's
isolation the way the sea Lanes had
already begun to change while the
lighthouse was under construction so
long ago had seemed to presage its
ultimate fate
exactly why the SNSB had chosen to build
their base there was not clear stranger
still they seemed to take a particular
interest in Saul's Lighthouse
particularly the lens they had been
given permission to use the Lighthouse
Lens in their experiments the purpose of
which Saul did not understand Saul was
annoyed by their intrusions and the
overall presence of the main two to
visit him a man by the name of Henry and
a woman named Suzanne Saul knew that
they were studying the shore and the
surrounding area or experimenting on it
their reasons eluded him
they were always present now taking
measurements and photographs dictating
statements under their bulky tape
recorders making their amateur movies
intent on finding
what
Saul knew of the stories surrounding the
shore but he did not buy into them he
thought the stories and whisperings to
be just that tall tales passed around
the everyday being reshaped into the
mysterious and the otherworldly
he knew the history of the shore here
the way that distance and silence
magnified the mundane
how into those spaces and the fog and
the empty line of the beach thoughts
could turn to The Uncanny and begin to
create a story out of nothing
but that was before Saul himself would
encounter something truly uncanny along
the shore
something beyond words
mysteriously one night the SNSB base on
failure Island burned down
there was no explanation given as to
what caused it
a short amount of time following this
event Saul saw something on the lawn
outside the lighthouse an object that
defied reason or explanation
the nature of which seemed unknowable
and unnamable it captivated him and
transfixed him it appeared to be some
kind of Otherworldly plant with eight
petals it was almost as if it was made
of light
whatever it was it was delicate beyond
measure yet perversely reminded him of
the four-ton Lins far above his head
the sun was a whispering Corona at his
back the heat had risen but there is a
breeze that lifted the leaves off the
Palmettos in a rattling stir the girl
was somewhere behind him singing a
nonsense song having come back off the
Rocks earlier than he'd expected
nothing existed in that moment except
for the plant and The Gleam he could not
identify he had gloves on still so he
knelt beside the plant and reached for
the glittering thing brushing up against
the leaves
was it a tiny shifting spiral of light
it reminded him of what you might see
staring into a kaleidoscope
except an intense White
but whatever it was swirled and glinted
and eluded his rough grasp and he began
to feel faint alarmed he started to pull
back
but it was too late
he felt a sliver into his thumb
there was no pain only a pressure and
then numbness but he still jumped up in
Surprise yowling and waving his hand
back and forth he frantically tore off
the glove examined his thumb aware that
Gloria was watching him not sure what to
make of him nothing now glittered on the
ground in front of him no light at the
base of the plant no pain in his thumb
slowly Saul relaxed nothing throbbed in
his thumb there was no entry point no
puncture he picked up the glove checked
it and could not find a tear
at that moment though Saul would remain
in denial about it for quite some time
something entered him it entered him and
waited he began to change slowly he
began to see things his dreams filled
with visions or premonitions and his
mind became continually flooded with a
strange sermon and the Hand of The
Sinner shall rejoice for there is no sin
in Shadow or in light that the seeds of
the Dead cannot forgive
over the course of acceptance Saul is
slowly taken over by the Light inside
him he knows deep down that eventually
what hides within him will come to the
surface and his own Consciousness would
be pushed aside fragmented and Scattered
during this time Saul is increasingly
disturbed by the behavior of the SNS
beam particularly Henry
one night Saul wakes to find Suzanne
Henry and a strange woman he did not
know in the lighthouse
he has caught them in the middle of
something but he does not understand
what
Suzanne and the woman he didn't know
stood by the door to the railing dressed
in all black with Henry on his knees in
front of them almost as if he'd been
dealt a blow
Suzanne looked defended as if he'd burst
in on them in their own home
but the stranger hardly acknowledged his
presence
stood there with arms crossed oddly
relaxed her hair was long and quiffed
she was dressed in an Overcoat dark
slacks and a long red scarf
something about the unknown woman
Disturbed The Lighthouse Keeper it was
her coldness and the way she disregarded
him she seemed to be treating him like
an annoying variable in one of their
experiments at this moment something
interesting happens Suzanne appears to
hypnotize Saul to calm him down this is
another clear tide that connects the
SNSB to the southern reach which made
widespread use of hypnotism in the
book's Annihilation and Authority
Suzanne's attempt however did not calm
Saul down instead he was filled with
fear
reading this section you get the sense
that they know something about what is
happening to Saul and that they might
have even caused it just get the hell
out Saul said and rinse the ax free
although it cost him held it high on the
handle because in such Close Quarters it
would be no use to him otherwise
there was such a terror in him now that
they wouldn't go that he couldn't make
them get the hell out while still in his
head a thousand lighthouses burned but
Henry just Shrugged said suit yourself
Henry almost contorted himself to avoid
brushing his soul as they passed by as
if Saul were made of the most delicate
Crystal the woman gave him a mysterious
Smile as she turned into the spiral
leading down
a smile full of teeth the identity of
the mysterious woman is never clearly
stated but there are hints given as to
who it could be I will go over this
later in the video
as time goes on Saul continues to have
dreams and Visions the time of ultimate
change is approaching he discovers one
night that the secret trapdoor in his
lighthouse is open from the open space a
light pours out
the light emanates from a glowing flower
a mirror of the one from his yard
a Pure White Blossom with eight petals
which had unfurled from the top of a
familiar plant whose Roots disappeared
into the papers below
the plant that it enticed him on the
lighthouse lawn so long ago to reach
down drawn by a glitter a gleam an
almost holy intensity Rose from
somewhere within and filled Saul up
along with a dizziness light was leaking
out of him now too coursing through the
trapdoor to communicate with what lay
below and there came the sensation of
something pulling him close holding him
tight of recognizing him
Saul lose his Consciousness at this
point and when he awakes he discovers
that he is again in the Watchtower of
the lighthouse Henry and Suzanne lay
Dead next to him with no discernible
wounds
when he climbs the ladder Saul discovers
something that defied belief
there was Henry alive holding a gun
this Henry is obviously a doppelganger
similar to the one seen in Annihilation
Henry was likely the first doppelganger
ever made by area X
the original Henry had been on the seon
side of the SNSB he believed that
whatever area X was or whatever caused
it or drove its primary function was a
God or Spirit but it had been something
else entirely it had remade him
seemingly in an attempt to suit its
purpose
I found it Saul like I said I would
or it found me
only it wasn't what I thought
do you know what it is Saul almost
pleading there was no good answer to
Henry's question
Saul manages to evade Henry and Escape
Into the Wilderness but he cannot Escape
what is inside him he can feel that his
end is near and that something new would
be born
something was about to Crest like a wave
something was about to come out of him
he felt weak and Invincible all at once
was this how it happened was this one of
the ways God came for you
he did not want to leave the world and
yet he knew now that he was leaving it
or that it was leaving him for Saul it
was although an entire universe was
opening up in his mind but it was
incomprehensible to him but a universe
was opening up in his head filled with
images he didn't couldn't understand a
flowering plant that could never die a
rain of white rabbits cut off in
mid-leap a woman reaching down to touch
a starfish in a tidal pool green dust
from a corpse blowing away in the wind
Henry standing Atop The Lighthouse
jerking and twitching receiving a signal
from very very far away
Saul is being given images of the
present past and future it seems the
particular image of Henry in
communication with something far away
gives a pretty clear suggestion that the
type of entity that we are dealing with
is either of an extraterrestrial or
extra dimensional nature the image of
the rabbits clearly references a future
experiment performed by the southern
reach we will discuss this particular
experiment later in the video saw also
sees various images from future
Expeditions that would eventually be
sent out into area X
Saul eventually comes to terms with the
fact that he cannot fight The Light
Within him is impossible to resist
finally he accepts what is happening
it was just a tiny thing
a splinter and yet it was as large as
entire worlds and he was never going to
understand it even as it took him over
his last thoughts before the thoughts
that were not his that were never going
to be his
perhaps there is no shame in this
perhaps I can bear this fight this
give in but not give up and project it
out behind him toward the sea Saul
unable to say the name just three simple
words that seemed so inadequate and yet
they were all he had left to use
Saul loses Consciousness then
he awakes as the Monstrous entity first
encountered in Annihilation the crawler
the place where he fell in the forest
becomes the tunnel in the earth referred
to an Annihilation as the tower
we learn from this chapter that the
Splinter is not from Earth
it is connected with a kind of mirror of
itself inside the lighthouse
within the Splinter is what Saul
describes as an entire universe
this is likely a reference to its
interdimensional nature
the Splinter and the flower of light
beneath the lighthouse seemed to be tied
to some other dimension perhaps multiple
Dimensions some force from that
Dimension could be using the Splinter as
a proxy to execute its purpose what that
purpose is I will attempt to decipher as
we continue this video
is never fully clarified whether or not
Saul's transformation into the crawler
and the creation of the tower was the
event that sparked the creation of area
X or if it was merely an event which
occurred parallel to it
either way all 1500 citizens along the
Forgotten Shore were annihilated
part two the Expeditions the experiments
the SNSB which was tied to the
government agency Central first
mentioned in book 2 Authority in some
way had been active for many years
before the event
there was something about the Forgotten
Shore that Drew them there perhaps
something about the nature of the place
facilitated the opening of doorways to
other places perhaps the sliver and its
mirroring flower appeared there because
there was no other place other than
there that it could appear
it is possible that the S and SB
themselves were the Catalyst for the
event that they had called something
from very far away to Earth or perhaps
they were studying something that had
been trapped there long ago
the key to this is the Lighthouse Lens
itself but we will get to that soon
enough
if the SNSB was in fact tied to Central
then that itself connects it to the
southern reach considering that Central
is also the agency behind the southern
reach program
we know that agents like Jackie
Severance and Whitby were some of the
earliest to study area X after the event
it is possible that Jackie and Whitby
had also been members of the SNSB at the
time it seems to be implied that Jackie
Severance was the mysterious woman in
all black who Saul discovered in the
lighthouse Tower late that night with
Henry and Suzanne we learn an authority
that Jackie who was apparently a
high-ranking member of central has a son
also tied to the agency
Jackie's son who is referred to in the
books as control is the main character
of the book Authority during his time as
the Director of the Southern reach he
does a lot of unraveling of the
organization's past or at least the
parts of it that are made visible to him
though he is the director of the
Southern reach he still answers to
Central we learn that many Expeditions
were sent into area X following the
initial Explorations some returned some
did not and some returned changed
it was mentioned that according to the
files the first expedition had
experienced such Horrors almost Beyond
imagining that it was a wonder that they
had sent anyone after that
but they had sent more countless more
the first book in the trilogy follows
the supposed 12th Expedition sent into
area X by the southern reach but we
later learned that that was merely the
current iteration of the 12th Expedition
as far more than 12 had been sent over
the last 30 years the current 12th
Expedition which is made up of the
protagonist of annihilation consisted of
four individuals the psychologist the
biologist the surveyor and the
Anthropologist not much is known about
the surveyor and the Anthropologist on
the 12th Expedition the psychologist is
initially introduced as the leader of
the Expedition but we learn in the
second book Authority that she had
actually been the director of the
Southern reach at the time willingly the
director whose name was Gloria had
chosen to join the Expedition she had in
fact grown up on the Forgotten Shore she
had known Saul the Lighthouse Keeper
during the events described before
the 12th Expedition had in fact not bit
her first Venture into the region even
after area X was formed she had visited
the lighthouse and returned she unlike
some did not experience any form of time
dilation the biologist is the main
protagonist of the first novel we take
in area X through her eyes as she
becomes increasingly more transfixed and
mesmerized by the beauty and horror of
the place her husband had been on the
previous Expedition he had returned but
not the same somehow deep down she had
known that it was not truly him she also
on some level hoped that she would find
the real him inside Area X
what exactly is happening inside Area X
is not immediately clear we know
basically that all biological life that
comes into contact with it was changed
DNA was copied and reincorporated into
other life in strange and bizarre forms
over the course of the first novel we
follow the biologist as she comes to
know the strangeness of the area and
comes to understand that the
organization the southern reach had been
lying about the nature of the
Expeditions from the beginning
eventually the biologists would come
face to face with the creature which she
had named the crawler I detailed the
experience of the biologist in the first
book in this video here Linked In the
description
area X is a place outside of our normal
perception of time it is not clear why
but time moves differently in area X
depending on where and when the border
into it was crossed
the biologists from book one experiences
30 years of time within area X During
the three-week period between
Annihilation and Authority
in Authority control comes across a
video on a previous experiment of the
Southern reach it involved them sending
rabbits through the invisible border of
area X
saw the Lighthouse Keeper was given a
vision of this particular experiment as
he transformed into the crawler
A Reign of white rabbits cut off in
mid-leap
as if in a reflexive Act of frustration
at the lack of progress the scientists
had let loose 2 000 white rabbits about
50 feet from the border in a clear-cut
area and herded them right into the
Border
in addition to the value of observing
the rabbits transition from here to
there the science division had some hope
that the simultaneous or near
simultaneous breaching of the Border by
so many living bodies might overload the
mechanism behind the Border causing it
to short-circuit even if just locally
this supposed that the Border could be
overloaded like a power grid they had
documented the rabbit's transition not
only with the standard video but also
with tiny cameras strapped to some of
the rabbit's heads
the resulting Montage had been edited
together use split screen for maximum
dramatic effect along with slow motion
and fast forwarded in ways that conveyed
and oddly flippant quality when taken in
aggregate as if even the video editor
had wanted to make light of the event to
somehow through an embedded irreverence
find a way to unsee it in all control
knew the video and digital library
contained more than 40 000 video
segments of rabbits Vanishing jumping
squirming atop one another as they form
sloppy rabbit pyramids in their efforts
not to be pushed into the Border
future Expeditions Beyond The Border
discovered no sign of the rabbits given
this information it would seem as though
area X was attempting to maintain a
certain ecosystem and simply weeded out
the excess rabbits this would make sense
because that many rabbits introduced at
once would be almost certain to form
into an invasive species putting area
X's curated ecological balance into
Jeopardy area X could have had an
unlimited amount of time to do this
considering that time is extremely
variable Beyond The Border as mentioned
before some Expeditions went in and
never returned some Expeditions came
back eerily unharmed and there were
those of course that came back fine but
different it is possible that some
Expeditions like the biologists spent
years and even decades within area X
before either dying of old age or Dying
by some other means or being transformed
some other biological form those that
came back unharmed simply entered area X
within a Time stream that was aligned
with our own and for whatever reason
were not infected by area X but those
who came back themselves but not have a
different explanation for whatever
reason area X made copies of things
doppelgangers I mentioned earlier that
Henry whose original died in the
lighthouse may have been the first
doppelganger that area X created in
Authority we also encounter ghostbird
the doppelganger of the biologist of the
12th Expedition
it is clear that those who return
themselves but not themselves were
actually doppelgangers this explains one
aspect this however does not explain how
those doppelgangers got out of area X
the books seemed to suggest that this
was through a form of teleportation the
tower which seems to be a kind of entity
of its own some kind of bizarre
inversion of the lighthouse formed
during the final merger of Saul's
Consciousness and the sliver possesses
at the bottom of it a strange light the
biologist in the first book fled from
the light terrified but control near the
end of book 3 jumps into it it seems
that the light at the bottom of the
tower is a kind of exit point but where
it leads seems to be random for some it
leads to outside of area X for others
elsewhere perhaps in book 2 Authority
control views the video of the first
expedition
on it he can see the doppelgangers of
the original members of the first
expedition entering the tower it is
pretty clear that this was the way in
which those who came back changed got
out of area X
it would seem that the futility of the
Expeditions grew with each additional
Mission by the time of annihilation it
did not seem as though they were
gathering much more information but for
whatever reason the Expeditions
continued they fed area X this has to be
tied to the motives of central but what
exactly those motives are are never
fully stated in the series we only know
that their interest was fixed upon area
X and that they had their eyes upon the
SNSB long before area X came into
existence
but what is area X well I've combed
through the text of these books and I
think I found the answer
part three
what is area X
what does it what
so what do we know
something not from here came into
contact with the Earth
the SNSB performed experiments on
failure Island their headquarters burned
down and shortly after Saul the
Lighthouse Keeper was pricked by the
strange flower
the government agency's Central
responsible for the southern reach was
also tied to S and SB and all of this is
somehow tied to Saul's Lighthouse Lens
which had once been on failure Island
the series does not connect all these
dots for you we have to do a bit of work
to figure out exactly what may be going
on
at this point area X seems like some
kind of biological machine left over by
an intelligent alien life from somewhere
else it is possible that it is from
another dimension or from far out in
space this is suggested by one of Saul's
Visions as the strange plant begins to
take him over
the star is no longer shown but flew and
scuttled across the sky
and the violence of their passage did
not bear scrutiny he had the sense that
something distant had come close from
far away that the Stars moved in this
way now because they were close enough
to be seen as more than tiny Points of
Light if I had to make an educated guess
I would say that whatever area X is is
From Another Dimension or at least
travels interdimensionally Saul sees it
as coming from beyond the stars because
that is the only way his human mind can
properly interpret it if it is a machine
it could be a machine designed to fix
broken environments or simply create
sustainable ones this would explain why
it essentially deleted the rabbits it is
also possible that it essentially
labeled humans as bad or perhaps
something about humans in particular
confused or baffled it this would
explain why the animals and vegetation
of ariex remain MO mostly the same only
improved while humans are sometimes
remade into doppelgangers that soon die
after or sometimes turned into animals
or even occasionally
stranger forms area X seems to sometimes
make mistakes one example being the
moaning creature
the biologists of the 12th Expedition
encounters the moaning creature during
her 30 years wandering area X resisting
being changed by the place the moaning
creature had once been human but had
become something utterly monstrous
eventually I came into a kind of
clearing an island of dirt covered in
anemic grass and bound by yet more Reeds
at the far end something pale and
grub-like and monstrous flailed and
moaned its limbs pummeling the Reed
floor the speed I had witnessed in the
past seemingly now unavailable to it
the creature had once been the
psychologist of the 11th Expedition her
husband had been on the same Expedition
even more horrifying it still had his
face but distorted unsettlingly the
creature was an abomination
and this face in its slumber-formed mask
of utter uncomprehending anguish the
mouth opened in a Perpetual o as it
moaned out its distress as its limbs
gouged at the ground as it made its
wounded halting progress in what
amounted to circles
the creature was blind its eyes had a
white film over them it slept there on
the forest floor as the biologist took
in the sight of it she recognized that
it was different from the other things
in area X it seemed to be a fluke as
though it was the result of area X
failing to react correctly within
conjunction with its purpose
this Beast should have been a dolphin
with an uncanny eye a wild boar that
acted as if it were new to its body
and perhaps it was part of an
intentional pattern and I just could not
see those outlines
but it looked like a mistake a misfire
by area X that had assimilated so much
so beautifully and so seamlessly
which made me wonder if my brightness
was a harbinger of some form of this
to disappear into the shoreline into the
anonymous reaches of the beach and wind
or the marshes did not really disturb me
perhaps never had
but this did
this blind relentless questing
had I tricked myself into believing that
letting the brightness overtake me would
be a painless even beautiful process
there was nothing beautiful about the
moaning creature nothing that didn't
seem a ghastly intervention
the current state of the 11th Expedition
psychologist in the moment makes you
wonder what became of some of the many
others who went into area X and never
returned what bizarre forms might they
exist in
it is also possible that area X is a
machine designed to communicate but that
because of the nature of the species
that created the machine we cannot
receive the message instead the message
itself harms us this would be like
humans attempting to communicate with
very tiny intelligent creatures on a
desk but the mere vibrations of our
voices destroy their cities and kill
them another metaphor would be a child
reaching out and touching a creature in
a tide pool that simple innocent curious
act could cause damage to the life in
that tide pool
the Curiosity or attempt to communicate
is not malicious and yet it brings
destruction simply due to the
incompatibility of our existences
all of that being said as I said before
the ultimate answer lies within the
lighthouse's lens
it was once the lighthouse used on
failure Island it is said that the boat
carrying the lens almost sank to Sea
when transporting it to the main Shore
there was something inside the lens and
that thing was area X this is
essentially confirmed in acceptance
she saw or felt deep within the
cataclysm Like A Reign of comets that
had annihilated an entire biosphere
remote from Earth
witnessed how one made organism had
fragmented and dispersed each minute
part undertaking a long and perilous
Passage through spaces between black and
formless punctuated by sudden light as
they came to rest scattered and lost
emerging only to be buried inert in the
glass of a lighthouse
and how when brought out of dormancy the
wire tripped how it had best as it could
regenerated and begun to perform a vast
and pre-ordained Function One
compromised by time and context by the
terrible truth that the species that had
given area X its purpose
was gone
the sliver
area X or the maid organism as ghostbird
calls it here was somehow inside of the
Lighthouse Lens on failure island or at
least a fragment of it was it is not
totally clear how it got there it is
possible that it was in a way summoned
into the lens by the SNSB or some
earlier group it is also possible that
the made organism initially landed in
the sand of the Haunted Shore and that
that sand was later formed into the lens
regardless in the end the lens was
brought into Saul's Lighthouse the SNSB
were experimenting on the lens perhaps
in an attempt to communicate with what
was incited something went wrong
whatever seal trapped the maid organism
within the lens was broken
and the sliver infected soul
it is possible that Jackie Severance
could have properly interacted with the
sliver avoiding what ultimately happened
but because it was Saul who would take
whatever it was inside him he became the
crawler this is just speculation however
it is just as likely that Jackie would
have had no different of a reaction than
Saul nonetheless he was in no way
prepared to receive whatever message or
to do whatever thing this entity wanted
of him his human mind was broken and he
was ushered Along by his sermon which
was the only way he had to interpret the
strange purpose of whatever was inside
him the fact that it appears as a sermon
is clearly related to Saul's past as a
pastor the religious connotations of the
word sermon which is used several times
in the book is another element that is
reminiscent of the work of Lovecraft the
sermon almost sounds like something that
would be written in the Necronomicon or
scribbled down by someone who had borne
witness to Eldridge Horrors in their
final moments of sanity
when you examine the words of the
crawler they in Eerie terminology
basically describe the purpose of area X
but interpret it through the lens of
Saul's brain
where lies the Strangling fruit that
came from the hand of The Sinner
I shall bring forth the seeds of the
Dead to share with the worms that Gather
in the darkness and surround the world
with the power of their lives while from
the dim-lit hulls of other places forms
that never were and never could be
writhe for the impatience of the few who
never saw what could have been in the
black water with the sun shining at
midnight those fruit shall come ripe and
in the darkness of that which is golden
shall split open to reveal the
revelation of the Fatal softness in the
Earth the Shadows of the Abyss are like
the Petals of a monstrous flower that
shall Blossom within the skull and
expand the Mind beyond what any man can
bear but whether it decays under the
Earth or above on Green Fields or out to
sea or in the very air all shall come to
Revelation and to Revel in the knowledge
of the Strangling fruit and the hand of
The Sinner shall rejoice for there is no
sin in Shadow or in light that the seeds
of the Dead cannot forgive and there
shall be in the planting in the shadows
a grace and mercy from which shall
Blossom dark flowers and their teeth
shall devour and sustain and Herald the
passing of an age that which dies shall
still know life in death for all that
decays is not forgotten and reanimated
it shall walk the world in the Bliss of
not knowing and then there shall be a
fire that knows the naming of you and in
the presence of the Strangling fruit its
dark flame shall acquire every part of
you that remains
the implications of all of this are
relatively clear
area X seems to be a fragment of another
world it could exist both on Earth and
in another dimension but it is at least
tied to another dimension in some way
its origin is unknown its creators a
long dead alien race destroyed by a
great cataclysm it is possible that it
came here by accident or was drawn here
by the actions of the SNSB or some prior
group The sliver which infected Saul was
like a seed the sermon is a
manifestation of Saul's own limited
interpretation of the sliver's purpose
and goal essentially the sermon is the
result of Saul's human brain attempting
to put the Unspeakable into words the
exact meaning of what he is experiencing
cannot be expressed in words I said
earlier that the birth of the crawler
could have happened parallel to the
event which created area X but I think
it is likely that it is the event itself
the purpose of area X is to construct
slash rebuild its own ecosystem but it
is encountering problems interacting
with Earth it is possible that whatever
the driving mechanism behind area X is
is broken this could be the reason that
it is struggling to properly integrate
this would explain the moaning creature
and the doppelgangers that die of cancer
area X is some kind of machine a made
organism it came here either from deep
within outer space or from even further
realms
an interesting moment in the series
comes in acceptance when Saul the
Lighthouse Keeper encounters the
doppelganger of Henry who has attached
mystical characteristics to area X
and God said let there be light
God set that song
and he has come from so far away
his home is gone but his purpose remains
would you deny him his new kingdom the
original Henry was intent on there being
a mystical nature to all of this so he
interprets it mystically referring to
area X as he with a capital H he clearly
sees it as a God he understands it in
his own way but he is somewhat correct
on a fundamental level area X is Orphan
technology it was given instructions and
his intent on carrying them out area X
continues to expand throughout the
series it is never clear if it ever
truly stops part 4. what she became
ghost bird and the biologist
I mentioned earlier that the biologist
from the first novel spent 30 years
within area X in the few weeks in
between Annihilation and Authority
some of the details about her experience
during that time are the most
interesting in the series it was during
this time period that she encountered
the moaning creature
the biologist somehow resisted the
brightness inside of her as it attempted
to change her for 30 years before she
decided finally to let it overcome her
but before doing so she wrote down her
last will and testament which detailed
her time within area X within area X she
came into contact with an owl but the
animal did not behave like a normal
animal she came to believe that it was
her husband who had been on the 11th
Expedition this was the form that area X
had changed him into
spends decades with him until his death
and once he dies she finally allows the
brightness to overcome her she becomes
something never seen before on Earth or
possibly even in this Dimension
ultimately she appears before her
doppelganger ghostbird who has developed
a separate identity of her own of course
the book describes the biologist's body
as coalescing out of the night and
flickering and stitching its way into
existence she was an immense
otherworldly creature that luminesced in
the night
vast bulk seething down the hill through
the forest with a crack and Splinter as
trees fell to that gliding yet ponderous
muffled Darkness reduced to kindling by
the muscle behind the emerald
luminescence that glinted through the
black
the smell that presaged the biologist
thick Brine and oil and some sharp
crushed herb the sound that it made as
if the Wind and Sea had been smashed
together and in the Aftershock they are
reverberated that same sonorous moan the
nature of the biologist current being
was essentially indescribable
she had been elevated to a level of
existence that no one born human had
ever been before
ghostbird was drawn to her though she
should have been terrified at the mere
sight of the biologist in her present
form
she communicated with her counterpart
through a kind of telepathy
the mountain that was the biologist came
up almost to the windowsill so close she
could have jumped down onto whatever
served as its back
the suggestion of a flat Broadhead
plunging directly into torso the
suggestion far to the east already
overshooting the Lighthouse of a vast
curve and curl of the mouth and the
flinks carved by dark ridges like a
whales
and the dried seaweed the kelp that
clung there
and the overwhelming ocean smell that
came with it the green and white stars
of barnacles on its back in hundreds of
miniature Craters of tidal pools from
time spent Motionless in deep water time
lost inside that enormous brain the
scars of conflict with other monsters
pale and dull against the biologist's
skin
it had many many glowing eyes that were
also like flowers or sea anemones spread
open the blossoming of many eyes normal
parietal and simple all across its body
a living constellation ripped from the
night sky her eyes ghostbird's eyes
staring up at her in a vast and
unblinking array as it smashed into the
lower floor seeking something as it sang
and moaned and hollered
at this moment ghostbird comes to the
realization that the biologist now
existed across countless places she had
been redesigned by area X transformed
into a creature who could Traverse
endless Landscapes land sea or stranger
she was not a monster but a marvelous
creature whose existence was
unparalleled
nothing monstrous existed here only
Beauty only the glory of good design of
intricate planning from the lungs that
allowed this creature to live on land or
at Sea to the huge gill slits hinted at
on the sides shut tightly now but which
would open to breathe deeply of seawater
when the biologists once again headed
for the ocean all of those eyes all of
those temporary title pools the
pockmarks and The Ridges the thick
sturdy quality of the skin an animal and
organism that had never existed before
or that might belong to an alien ecology
that could transition not just from land
to water but from one remote place to
another with no need for a door and a
border staring up at her with her own
eyes seeing her this is a pivotal moment
thematically in the series because it
essentially clarifies that area X was
never trying to destroy anything
in its own way it was trying to help in
this series we see the terrible things
that humans are willing to do in order
to investigate area X the endless
Expeditions ending in the loss of
countless lives the brutal animal
experiments area X was merely attempting
to not only make the things it
encountered compatible with its own
ecosystem but to also improve upon those
things and when it worked it worked
beautifully the biologist essentially
evolves into what is the opposite of the
moaning creature whereas the moaning
creature seems like a fluke a mistake a
result of area X's inability to work
properly with human material the
biologist essentially becomes a perfect
being hypersintient and capable of
unimaginable things
at the very core this is a story about
humanity and its conflict with the
natural world nature is reclaiming the
Earth it is a new kind of nature a
nature never before seen by humans but
nature nonetheless is this nature
inherently bad or evil simply because it
does not include us at least in our
current form the answer is
good and bad are relative But ultimately
it is bad for us specifically
and that is the nature of true Cosmic
horror the Eldritch horrors of
lovecraft's work aren't Horrors because
they specifically want to harm humans
there is no cause to assume
anthropocentrism here
they act out their business indifferent
to us and if their business harms Us in
the process then so be it
area X and the changes that it makes to
our environment can be seen in some
sense as a metaphor for Humanity and our
effect on the environment in the real
world
through our existence we alter the
nature of things around us to suit our
own purposes this sometimes has
devastating effects on certain
ecosystems and species the key
difference here is however that area X
operates presumably not knowing the
effect that it is having on Humanity
while humanity is aware of the effect on
its environment
there's a lot going on in this Trilogy
so there is bound to be some things I
didn't cover in this video like what are
the actual motivations of central what
is the end result of area X I will
likely cover these other topics in
future videos thanks for watching guys
all right guys it's time yet again for
patreon questions now if you want to ask
me a question and be featured in one of
my videos you can sign up at patreon.com
ideas of Ice and Fire supporting the
patreon helps support the Channel first
question I've just read Larry Nevins the
moat in the God's eye and would love to
hear your thoughts on this or any of
niven's work well I have not read the
moat in the God's eye but I have read
some of the Ring World Books and I think
they're really interesting for their
exploration of
macro engineering you know the concept
of Mega structures and how a society
might go about building a megastructure
and sustaining a megastructure and how
exactly disastrous The Fallout could be
if something bad occurs and this
megastructure such as a ring world is no
longer sustainable so I definitely
recommend the Ring World Books so the
next question is from Mark Thomas thanks
for taking questions have you read or
plan to read Gene Wolf's book of the new
Sun series I think it would pair well
with your Hyperion cantos so the book of
the new sun to me is very interesting
because it's one of those science
fiction series that reads more like a
fantasy series especially at the
beginning and it's also a series that
does not give you very much information
about the world or what's going on you
have a very limited perspective
initially and so does the main character
in the book you start off in the series
knowing basically what he knows which is
virtually nothing and as the book goes
on the world expands and you start to
learn more about the history of this
place and it's very very long mostly
forgotten pass and it's an intriguing
read for sure that has like a very
classic feel to it would recommend
alright so the next questions from
Donovan Carr have you read Stephen
Baxter's time ships it is a sequel to HG
wells's fantastic novel The Time Machine
it was officially authorized by the
wells estate could I possibly implore
you to do a deep dive into Wells
original time machine followed by a deep
dive into Baxter's time ships there are
far too many interesting things in these
books not to delve into them interesting
well I actually have not read the time
ships but the time machine was actually
one of my favorite books as a kid and I
have not read it since I was like 12
years old but I do love the work of HG
Wells and it would be interesting to
explore some of his work with an adult
perspective so I will keep that in mind
thank you for your suggestion the next
question is from Alexander who are your
favorite aliens in sci-fi both literary
and on screen and what do you find
compelling about them well I feel like
this changes on a regular basis for me
but I guess right now I've been thinking
a lot about the board from Star Trek the
Next Generation and it's really because
of what they represent the boric are
essentially this hive-minded organism
that exists only to assimilate and to
propagate itself individuality does not
exist there is only the Borg and
particularly in the Next Generation the
Borg always represented such a threat to
the values of the Federation which are
you know independent freedom and the
ability to seek out your own goals in
life the Borg also get even more
interesting I think in Voyager when the
character seven of nine is introduced
because she is a character org that is
freed from the collective and an
interesting thing that's dived into in
Voyager is the fact that it's quite
lonely outside of the collective because
it is kind of like easy to go along with
the crowd but once you've been wrapped
up in the crowd and going along with the
mob so long it's kind of really
difficult to become your own person
again afterwards so that is part of
seven of Nine's character development
throughout the course of Voyager season
4 on anyway I just think the Borger is
super interesting and there's a lot of
parallels uh that I see happening now in
real life when I think about the Borg
alright so the last question comes from
Charles Lee Thorpe a few of the
technologies that science fiction has
been grappling with for a few years now
are practically Upon Us genetic
engineering cybernetics AI how do you
view these what lessons might we draw
from great works of Science Fiction that
might offer hope or caution
well a lot of it scares me because I
wonder if humanity is you know prepared
for the onslaught of new technologies
and the effects that they're going to
have on our society and I get the
impression that we're not but it kind of
doesn't matter whether we are not
because it's here now and the thing is
you can't stop scientific progress but I
think what's important is you know
discussing you know our advancements And
discussing the philosophical
implications of our technological
advancements openly because we don't
have open conversations about Ai and how
it's going to affect the world then it's
just gonna happen and we're not gonna be
prepared for it or know how to deal with
it so we have to actually have these
conversations
and I think that's the most important
thing I think a lot of people
immediately see something that they
don't like or that scares them and they
immediately want to shut it down we do
not like this
shut it down but that's the thing you
cannot shut it down you cannot put the
magic of Technology back in the box once
it's been released so we have to find
ways to cope and deal with it and that
comes from conversation that is the
first stop
all right so that is the end of patreon
questions please check out my patreon
and if you're interested in interacting
with the community more you can also
join the Discord Link in the description
all sorts of cool science fiction chats
happening there all the time thanks guys
peace out
[Music]
foreign